Hey, David, whatever happened to Donald Trump's
wall and does it matter for 2020?
So all you need to know is that Trump is claiming
he did it.
Trump is claiming he did it.
Now, you might remember when he was running,
Trump's promise was by the end of my first
term, we'll have a wall across the entire
u.s.-mexico border that was never going to
happen.
Trump also said Mexico would pay for it.
That was never going to happen, and none of
it has happened.
Trump has been able to finagle getting about
looks like 150, 160 miles of wall starting
to be built, some of which will be completed
by November.
But what you need to understand is, despite
that obviously being a failure by Donald Trump
to do what he promised to do, he's going to
claim victory and a lot of his followers are
going to fall for it.
So, first of all.
There will be very little fact checking of
Trump about you promised a wall across the
entire border what the hell happened.
If it happens, Trump will say, listen, Democrats
got in the way.
Corona virus got in the way.
And I built what I was able to do.
If it weren't for Democrats, I would have
built the whole thing.
But we've had a huge success.
We have 150 miles, bill or whatever.
And I did everything I could.
And it is a victory.
We have more miles now than we ever had before.
You all get it right.
So he's going to claim victory no matter what.
And that is all that matters.
Optics is all that matters.
It is this bizarre, sort of like raw shock
test of a wedge issue.
I had people calling me on live calls a year
and a half ago, two years ago.
There's this crazy Republican caller, Doug,
who sometimes calls and he's from Southern
California.
And he was saying, the wall, the wall, the
wall, the wall.
And I said, well, if Trump doesn't build the
wall during his first term, will you still
vote for him for reelection?
And he basically said probably, which means
that it doesn't really matter if he builds
the wall, even just claiming to have succeeded
despite the oppression of Democrats on the
wall.
Most Trump ists are going to vote for him
anyway because they see Biden as worse.
It's an incoherent explanation that Corona
virus and Democrats prevented him from from
building it.
Republicans have also gotten the way of giving
him the funding that he wants.
We've talked about all of that.
But the 2020 election is going to be primarily
a referendum on the state of the economy at
the time and what that means about Trump's
management of the country.
Of course, it will be affected by Corona virus,
but Trump's actual handling of the virus itself
is mostly baked in already.
It will be a matter of do we have a sort of
ad between the waves that helps Trump in November
or not?
I don't believe that the wall is going to
be a factor in any way.
People who are against the wall are probably
already not voting for Trump.
People who are who voted for Trump in 2016
and hear him say, we did it.
I made one hundred and fifty miles and will
do more my second term.
They're gonna fall for it.
I do not believe it's going to make a difference
if you disagree with me.
I, of course, want to hear from you.